many of us have been asked to find x
but for something to be found it must
first have been lost
on the number line life was well defined
[Music]
with prized fields and blue skies
things were pretty organized
until one
non-ordinary day
when all patterns went astray
this is the story of x
who was born to shock and surprise
with an equation too tough to analyze
x's parents were 40 and 42
but after 41 came between them
40 had moved on with someone new
[Music]
growing up x's life felt far from
optimal
since without a value how can one be
valuable
one day
a school trip to the function fair
turned to despair
when x was told
you must have this value to ride
and was sent instead
to the minimal slide
that night at the times table relational
emotions were unstable
x blamed 42 for their missing value
42 snapped back
it isn't all about you
if only you were numeric that would
simplify my life too
[Music]
i'm tired of this pointless search for
your value
x slammed their door
and began to cry
42 cooled off
not
but no reply
x
i'm sorry for what i said to you
i was out of order it wasn't true
please know that i value you
but already outside
eyes blurred by misery
x had not heard 42's apology
untying their old boat
cold and scared
x hadn't realized that their pain was
shared
every night 42 worked on finding x
even when the math became complex
42 worked with increased ferocity their
working was an absolute monstrosity
they'd even found a fictional velocity
x sailed out far into the ocean
battling the elements and their emotions
when a sinusoidal storm rose with an
unbalanced force
sending the boat and x curving off
course
spotting an island
x gave a shout
before the boom swung round and knocked
x out
washed up on the beach
x barely survived
but was discovered by a group of
eyes part of an ancient numerical
civilization
who had an archaic system classification
x woke to an emperor's voice who peered
down giving x no choice
this one will be useful later
i declare them a 10
a gladiator
then m
lean down with a menacing demeanor and
said
you can prove your value in the arena
[Applause]
x thought maybe they'd found a way to
belong
with this group of tens
so big and strong
but something felt so terribly wrong
everyone expected x to fight
swords drawn the crowd roared with
delight
when two angles of radiant light
flew through x's line of sight
their movement
inspired x to try
folding up
into an eye
this way x escaped from the jailhouse
grateful
for all the practice of trying to be
someone else
then
down the shaft of an old mine x fell
to the axis line
lost in a dark and dingy nook
x discovered an ancient book
it spanned all of mathematics
from algebra to geometry to quadratics
x was shocked to see on almost every
page that their name was center stage
blinking
bewildered it made no sense x flicked to
the back with suspense where the answers
should be listed but nothing there no
answers existed
the walls around x then congruently
shifted
glowing beads on an abacus drifted
to reveal
a bright and welcoming direction
much better than here x thought on
reflection
[Music]
x was on cloud nine
this place was divine
it was hard to define but unlike
anything else on the number line
there were strange symbols ex had never
seen before
it wasn't clear what they even stood for
one said
hello x come through
i'm y it's nice to meet you
welcome to the origin
the place where number lines begin
why was the first unknown x had talked
to so x asked
do you know your value
why not it replying
and so shall you
let me change your point of view
why led x on a tour of math that was
wonderfully obscure
then why said
knowing your value can be an irrational
endeavor
pie knows theirs but will be chasing it
forever
you must come to grips with the fact
math is not about your value
math is about relationships
[Music]
you and i
can form a line
a circle
or an ellipse
we're like magicians with transformative
tricks
[Music]
and with that the whole grid
is at our fingertips
seeing that it's okay to be unknown
x said
let's solve this problem of getting me
home
[Music]
on x's return
42 was overjoyed
saying
life without you felt like zero a
complete void
x felt a healing deep in their heart
at this reunion of broken parts
42 invited x into their exclusive space
where there was a briefcase
full of equations and formulae half
erased
42 proved to x that they'd always been
working never given up hope never
stopped searching
x and 42 embraced x happily crying
to see how hard 42 had been trying
before the papers could cause any more
pain
x threw them out
into a new domain
an answer was no longer needed
and as the tears receded
x said
to blame you 42
was wrong
i found my value
it was here
all along
[Music]
you